the legislation that I introduced in
Congress was called the protect women's
sports act there were a number of
leading Democrats on the house floor
with really harmful Words which sends a
message to anyone else who's even
thinking about the truth step in line
and shut up that's the message that they
sent comply are you hopeful about
the future of the country
in all honesty
all right we're here with a woman who
needs no introduction but I'll give one
anyway Tulsi gabbard is a former
congresswoman former presidential
candidate veteran
um thanks for being here talking to me
great to be here Matt thank you so I
guess we'll start with uh I mean
obviously the reason you've been in the
news most recently to announce that
you're leaving the Democrat Party
your exact words were uh an elitist
cabal of War mongers among other very
accurate labels yes
so can you uh can you walk me through
the that problem even like back to the
beginning when you first started
thinking that you had to make this move
can you kind of walk through that it's
something that has been building up over
time uh I don't think there was one
exact specific moment uh where I knew
that this was uh what had to be done but
look going all the way back from when I
was running for president and seeing
even in that election in the Democratic
Primary in 2020 Democrat leaders working
with the for-profit corporate media
interfering in our democracy by limiting
who voters were exposed to when I made
the decision to run for president I
naively thought like hey you know I know
this is going to be tough it's going to
be a rough campaign
um we'll have a lot of challenges to
overcome but at least I will have as
Fair a shot as anyone else running for
president on the debate stage through
the media to make my case to the
American people about why I wanted to
serve them in this way but literally on
the very day that I announced my
candidacy in January of 2019 uh the
first like shot was fired from NBC News
starting the whole Russian troll asset
nonsense and so it was a very
eye-opening experience throughout that
time are you saying you're not a Russian
spy that is true okay all right I am I
wasn't sure for the record okay don't
believe Hillary Clinton or anything she
has to say I remember hearing uh when
you're running for president that that's
uh
I believe I'm correct in this that after
at least a few of the debates you were
in you were the most Googled yes
candidate on the stage what did that
that was obviously the goal right
because coming in heart you know most
people in the country didn't know who I
was and so we had hoped that that first
debate I think it had the highest number
of viewers than any other debate that
followed the viewership progressively
dropped off over time I think as people
realized like hey this is just political
theater there's not actual uh real
substantive debate happening but
um again that was a sign of what was to
follow when after I was the most Googled
candidate you know we had our Google ads
account set up hoping that that would be
the case and then Google suspended the
account with no explanation uh no
reasoning and would not respond to us in
our our uh asked to say hey tell us
what's wrong tell us what we got to fix
how do we get our account back up as
quickly as possible it was radio Silence
from them until magically at one point
our account was just reinstated
uh so how long was it was it I I don't
think I heard that how long is it down
uh I mean it was down for at least a day
but it was through that Peak period when
people were actively searching and
looking and that was why I filed a
lawsuit against Google to make that
point that if the permanent Washington
the power elite big tag you know the
leaders of the Democrat Party big me
they can interfere in voters who are
just like oh hey I saw her on TV let me
let me learn more about her a sitting
member of Congress running for president
just imagine how much interference and
what kind of impact they can have on our
elections at any level controlling what
and what what the voter is able to see
and hear and learn about the people that
they want to vote for the labor
Department's Consumer Price Index which
catalogs the cost of good Services food
and rent Rose 0.4 percent over the month
of August double what many economists
had anticipated perhaps worse core
inflation which excludes food and gas
prices saw the highest increase last
month that it's seen since August 1982.
what does the current Administration
doing to quell The Surge of inflation
spending more taxpayer dollars of course
don't bury your head in the sand while
your savings deplete diversify into gold
with perch gold today all you got to do
is text Walsh tube 989-898 and Birch
gold will send you a free info kit on
protecting your savings with gold in a
tax sheltered account the experts over
at Birch gold have almost 20 years of
experience in converting IRAs and 401ks
into precious metal IRAs with an A plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
countless five star reviews and
thousands of satisfied customers why
haven't you checked them out yet text
Walsh to 989-898 and Birch gold will
send you a free info kit on diversifying
into tax free gold take the necessary
steps to hedge against inflation today
and protect your hard-earned money get
your free info kit by texting Walsh
298-9898 now so you talk about with the
Democrat Party the kind of corruption
and this uh
incestuous relationship between the
Democrats and the media do you find that
you have
ideological differences with the
Democrat Party fundamentally or is it
mostly
very much so and and increasingly over
time you know the party that I joined
back in 2002 when I ran for the state
house in Hawaii was a party that was
still and especially so in my home state
of Hawaii very much a Big Ten inclusive
party very much a party that was about
uh fighting for working people
um it was a party that stood up still
for free speech for you know civil
liberties civil rights
um you know individual freedoms uh over
time we have come to this point where
today's Democrat Party doesn't stand for
any of those things it's become a party
that is of buying for the elite it has
become a party that is actively trying
to undermine our fundamental freedoms
and rights a party that is hostile
towards uh not only Free Speech but
freedom of religion and a party that has
become the war party uh some of the
criticisms that I saw coming from
Democrat leaders and Talking Heads when
I announced announced my decision to
leave was oh of course she's going to go
join those anti-war people uh obviously
not referring to to the Democrat Party
so they've just given up the anti-war
apparently when I was growing up that
was is Iraq war and right code pink and
it was it was the Democrats were
definitely the anti-war party but right
that's not the case anymore it is
clearly not the case clearly in the
pocket of the military-industrial
complex and that's been evident through
uh you know the recent votes that have
taken place uh as this escalation of
this proxy war against Russia is going
on and sending tens of billions of
dollars to Ukraine not a single Democrat
not a single Democrat not even those who
claim to be the so-called Progressive
Champions voted against that funding it
was Republicans in the house and the
Senate who were the sole opposing voices
or even those just saying hey let's
answer the basic questions about what is
our objective what are we trying to
accomplish let's let's make sure we know
if we're sending money to to go fund
this war where is that money going and
how can we be held to account for those
taxpayer dollars to our voters none of
that was allowed to happen and the
questions that were being asked were
coming from Republicans are you worried
that we're barreling into a nuclear
conflict deeply concerned you think
that's a plausible thing to worry about
I think that is exactly where we are and
we should all be concerned about that we
should all be demanding answers and
action from leaders people in Congress
and the Biden administration of why they
have allowed us to get to this point
where we are closer to the to the brink
of nuclear war than we have been before
and why the Biden Administration isn't
using its position to push for a
negotiated peaceful end to this war that
that is the best way to help the people
of Ukraine and that's the best way for
us as As Americans in the world to avoid
nuclear catastrophe what's the reaction
been like ever since your major
announcement particularly on the left or
I don't know if you still had any
friends in the Democratic Party do a
couple what uh what was that reaction
like people I I've gotten some nice
messages from from a few folks who are
either uh you know still in a Democrat
Party or even still holding office I've
been speaking uh the truth and about my
criticism to the Democrat Party for a
few years now and so those who had a
problem with that have stopped talking
to me a long time ago which is part of
the problem is is an unwillingness to
have an honest conversation about how to
be better
um even as a party and focus more on
fighting for people rather than power in
Washington but the thing that has been
heartening to me is how many people I've
just heard from across the country and
different places that I've gone in the
last week are people who are Democrats
or who were Democrats who say
um you know I've been through what
you're going through uh thank you for
saying the things that I've been feeling
and have been frustrating me and and
really this hunger and desire for
leaders who exercise courage and
actually speak the truth not only about
the Democrat Party but really about a
lot of the issues that you've been
working on the things that are affecting
their kids in schools uh every day the
things that are affecting our
communities with regards to crime and
police and law enforcement borders the
things that are obvious to most people
who are paying attention but the things
that somehow leaders in Democrat Party
are completely ignoring or creating this
Rosy fantasy picture of something that
just doesn't exist
are you gonna be a Republican
it's not something thinking about I
don't have to think about that
um I am an independent and I'm just
going to continue to do what I have been
doing frankly
if you had to put a label on your uh
on your ideological
persuasion would you put it can you put
a label on it what would you call
yourself
none of the labels that exist have ever
worked for me uh primarily because they
mean such different things to different
people uh so I I just like I'm on Team
America and I take the oath that I took
both as a soldier as well as a member of
Congress to support and defend the
Constitution very seriously
so uh that's my Foundation that's my
focus and all of the other labels to me
don't matter in this country if they're
attached to people who aren't grounded
in that place on that Foundation
um
put your spot on one other question
because I'm sure you've maybe this is
more like fan fiction but I've seen I'm
sure you've seen people saying what
about Tulsa gabbard as a VP
on a republican ticket in 2024. what do
you think about that I I don't know I
don't know it's I I don't really deal in
the hypotheticals and it's hard to
I think it's hard for anybody to really
look at 2024 without looking at what's
going to happen in the next few weeks in
this election because it will have such
a direct impact on on the the challenges
and the things that we're dealing with
every day now including nuclear war what
do you think happens in 2022
my hope is that there are more Americans
who even if they're afraid to speak up
in their everyday lives at work amongst
friends or family because of this cancel
culture we live in that they exercise
their freedom to go and cast their vote
for people who stand for Freedom who
stand for the well-being of our country
and against this this radical so-called
woke agenda that the the Democrat party
in power is shoving down our throats
I also want to ask you you mentioned
that your situation with Google and uh
we know what happened with uh the hunter
Biden laptop story yes big Tech
censorship so where do you stand on does
the government have a role in preventing
or regulating the sort of big Tech
censorship and and is there any role
there for the government do you think I
think that uh and this is something I
worked on in Congress that that section
230 that provides these big Tech social
media companies with the liability
protection
um it needs to be fixed and it needs to
be reformed because they have this
protection uh given the fact that they
are platforms but they're acting like
they are news companies essentially and
as they pick and choose whose voices get
to be here they're not that neutral
Arbiter of this Open Marketplace of
ideas
um
that law is very outdated and the
language is problematic and that that is
I think the first step that needs to
change
uh and of course I want to talk to you
about the issue that one of the reasons
that you're here you'll be yeah well by
the time this comes out you will have
spoken at our uh rally in Nashville the
rally Dan child mutilation when did you
start sort of getting invested in that
issue and uh just like talk about your
your views on that yeah I mean I it
started while I was in Congress a good
friend of mine is Congressman Mark Wayne
Mullen from Oklahoma we were elected at
the same time
um I've gotten to know he's he is
running to be the U.S senator from
Oklahoma and I I I'm going to go and
help campaign for him but I've gotten
really close with him and his family
he's got three little girls
um all of them are very competitive
wrestlers along with his sons and you
know this whole effort to undermine and
redefine Title IX was what started to
get me really interested in um just the
the insanity of
those pushing for this change not
rejecting the truth rejecting the truth
that there are biological differences
between men and women and then seeing
how that has progressed to what we're
seeing now where you know the director
of Health and Human Services is
essentially threatening Child Protective
Services to come and take your child
away unless you as a parent provide this
gender affirming care which leads to you
know these these hormone treatments and
irreversible surgeries that more and
more we're seeing cause such incredible
and long-lasting harm to kids uh
essentially this Administration pushing
for and approving of of child abuse and
so I think like a lot of people The more
I've learned about it the more incensed
I've become in in uh that this is
happening and that
we're not even allowed to talk about it
we're not even allowed to raise concerns
about it as you showed in your
documentary that there's no conversation
or dialogue that they will allow around
this when did this from from the
perspective of a lot of people that I
talked to it it sort of they what I
always hear is that oh it seems like
this stuff started five years ago and
like it came out of nowhere the gender
ideology and generous fluid and all that
kind of thing now of course in reality
like what I get into in the film you
could trace it back
to the mid-20th century you can actually
go even further back than that if you
want to
but it does seem as though
five six seven years ago is when it kind
of exploded onto the mainstream and
that's especially when it seems as
though the Democrat Party became uh
totally invested in gender ideology did
you did when did you start to notice
that within the Democrat Party because I
the Democrat Party of uh you know when
Barack Obama was running for president
this never came up I don't remember him
ever talking about
how men should be in women's restroom so
when did you start to notice I think it
was around it was around that time it
was a few years before I left Congress
when these topics started to come up and
I think previous to that it was always
just like hey
you go live your life however you want
to live your life it's a free country
but once that turned into something that
was impacting the safety of kids in
bathrooms and locker rooms obviously
impacting kids competing in sports uh
you know scholarships future
professional opportunities and then now
what we're seeing with
people really pressuring kids and
parents into these kinds of treatments
that will harm them for the rest of
their lives you know as at ages where
they're not equipped to make these
decisions and that's again that's what's
so great about your film was
um making those comparisons of like okay
well as a kid who's five six seven eight
years old you know on any given day they
may be Superman or they may be this or
they may be that how do you how do you
then sit there and tell them okay well
you're gonna go and have this change
made to your body that that you can't
come back from I'm curious to get your
Insight on this again as someone who
spent so much time around you know
elected Democrats
why are they so focused on this issue
now I mean daily wire just reported on a
poll that showed that 80 of Americans
are opposed to gender transitions for
minors yeah 80 including a majority slim
majority but majority of Democrats and
then like 97 of Republicans and vast
majority of Independents so it it seems
like it's a very unpopular position
certainly to be as uh gung-ho about it
as they are yeah so why why have they
made this what's going on why are they
doing this you know it it doesn't make a
lot of sense there's just what I can say
is there is so much fear that has been
created
um because you know when I talk about
how the party is being controlled by
this Elite cabal of war mongers and
radical woke ideologues
they it's they won't allow anyone to
disagree they won't allow anyone to
express concern or ask these kinds of
questions and so they're pushing their
agenda of which this is a central focal
point
um and other Democrats see how people
like I'm treated and smeared and
attacked both online and in the media
and they're afraid they're afraid to say
anything even though I believe in their
heart they know that this is not right
it doesn't make sense and it's it's
really dangerous in the effect that it's
having on kids and parents and families
but this this culture of fear and
um you know the these fanatical
ideologues saying it's not enough to say
like okay like oh fine if you know yes
we want to take care of everyone and
make sure no one is harmed they've got
to go out there and you know you got to
stand on the street corner you got to
March and hold the sign and use the
bullhorn and prove how much you believe
in whatever their Narrative of the day
is there's a lot of people who are
really afraid to stand up and say what
is obvious to most others which is the
truth
when you were when you were actually in
Congress uh you talk about the
the backlash you get on social media and
the media but did you have
actual leadership in the Democrat Party
coming to you and saying you need to get
in line yes they did yes uh the
legislation that I introduced in
congress with my friend Mark Wayne
Mullen was called the protect women's
sports act and it was really just
centered around I didn't mention the
word trans or gender identity or
anything else it just said we need to
uphold the original intent of Title IX
that was created out of a recognition of
the biological difference between males
and females the male and female sex and
there were a number of people leading
Democrats on the house floor who came up
to me after we introduced that
legislation uh with really
um
uh really harmful words I'll say to me
harmful and critical words of how dare
you uh introduce this legislation again
no room for any dialogue no room for any
conversation about it whatsoever the
backlash was strong uh both in the house
as well as online and in the media again
which sends a message to anyone else
who's even thinking
what we were doing the thinking about
the truth
um shut up stand you know step in line
and shut up that's the message that they
sent comply
being there for eight years is it uh
is the corruption in DC as bad as just
regular Joe's like myself assume you
know we have no inside knowledge but you
should use a word see when you use the
word like Elite cabal
speaking of someone who was in DC for
for eight years
like that that means something because
it's it's like you you were there so
is that really how it works it is as
corrupt as you would imagine but the
problem is it is the norm there so it's
not it's not seen as something
that's bad you know when you look at all
these stories about insider trading and
and the decisions that are made uh by
leaders and kind of the normal
day-to-day practice of the wheeling and
dealing it is their norm and they don't
see anything wrong with it which is
exactly the problem they're so far out
of touch with reality and what is
obvious to most Americans across the
country
um that
they're going about their daily lives
and if you were to tell them like yeah
what you're doing is corrupt they would
like how dare you this is not who I am
I'm doing this for the right reasons and
all this other stuff do they believe
that I I do I believe it about
themselves I do yes I believe that that
when they look in the mirror they got no
issue with who they see looking back at
them
okay that's even more frightening it is
in a lot of ways it is are you uh are
you hopeful about
the future of the country in all honesty
I am very concerned
but what gives me hope is
um the hearts of the American people I
have had the opportunity it's what
inspired me when I ran for president
sitting in the room standing in the room
with people from all different ends of
the political Spectrum who really truly
deeply love this country and who share
the same concerns that I do about our
future it's what I've heard from people
over this last week from all ends of the
political spectrum and so my hope lies
in in the hearts and the hands and the
votes of the American people that more
and more people are realizing who we
choose as our leaders matter and it has
a direct impact on our kids and our
communities and our future and so the
hope that I have
um is in the people and our ability to
make change but we've got to do it
that's a strong place to end but I do
have to ask you one other question that
I ask every single person
that I ever meet really okay I have to
ask you is uh you know we hear a lot
about UFO sightings
so where do you stand on that where do
you stand on Aliens UFOs have they been
have they visited I don't doubt I I
don't I'm a big Believer by the way this
is this is I'll tell you this is not my
area of expertise but I I believe that
they are out there
whoever they are some of these UFO
sightings that we're hearing from the
military yeah it doesn't surprise me
it doesn't surprise me again I don't I
don't spend time looking at this stuff
or or reading about it but I see the
headlines and my stories come out and it
doesn't surprise me
well I'll I'll mark you down as a True
Believer that's not quite accurate but
uh Tulsa gabbard thanks so much for
talking it's great talking to you